i'm gonna owe you an apology after this
so this uh stephen colbert clip
uh was going viral today this is from
his show last night it's uh him dancing
around with vaccines it's about a minute
long that's all we're gonna show you and
i just to apologize in advance for this
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
vaccine
[Applause]
all right so i want to be very clear
about something first off i do apologize
for showing that secondly if you thought
anything there was enlightening or
interesting or funny um i henceforth
banned you from watching this program
we can't have people like you
the unsullied we can't have you watching
this show uh what you might have found
interesting about that was not any of
the just it's so gross it's just so
gross imagine if trump was president and
the entire political and media machine
supported trump's ideas and there were
dancing vaccinated people around a late
night host they would everyone else
would be screaming that this is
government propaganda i mean all right
you guys get you get all that but did
you notice that no one in the audience
is wearing a mask now i have no doubt
they forced them all to be vaccinated
and
i think they shoot that in new york city
that's in the old letterman
building if i'm not mistaken the old ed
sullivan theater um so i'm sure they had
to show their vaccine passport but we
are being told that people with vaccines
are still getting sick they're still
transmitting it old joe biden when he
was getting his booster shot on that
theater set yesterday or the day before
he was wearing a mask while the other
guy was wearing a mask this is all by
design this intentionally confusing
messaging where some people can be
vaccinated some people don't have to be
vaccinated some people can wear masks
rich people can go to met gala events
like aoc and not bass while the workers
have to be
masked you know they're going to scream
that vaccines you now you need booster
shots but they'll have an audience full
of people
that are not wearing masks and yet if
there was an anti-vaxx rally they'd
scream that it was a super spread or
event or if there was just any political
rally that wasn't a lefty political
rally but i'd more uh more broadly talk
about this uh this ridiculous clip just
to show you how horrible
mainstream
comedy has become these people that man
thinks he's a comedian and jimmy kimmel
blackface jimmy kimmel thinks he's a
comedian
and last week by the way i think some of
you know this
greg gutfeld i was on greg gutfeld show
on wednesday night in new york city i
believe on thursday night or might have
even been on wednesday night it was
wednesday night it was it was wednesday
night on the very same night that i was
on greg gutfeld's show
all of the late night show hosts except
for gutfeld so talking about colbert
and kimmel and who's the fat guy on cbs
that australian kid or corden or cardin
or whatever his name is and uh trevor
noah on the daily show that nobody
watches anymore but you're not allowed
to say that otherwise you'd be called
racist they all did a climate night and
it was just an abject disaster nobody
watched it meanwhile i was on gutfeld
that night and gutfeld greg gutfeld he's
got about five people that work for his
show i mean i know the show pretty
intimately they got a makeup girl he's
got like one writer they got a booker
all great people fantastic people
they're crushing it they are number one
in late night because you've basically
got
a bunch of leftist clones who only know
how to preach to the choir
and gut fell doing a largely unscripted
show that's edgy and kind of fun and a
little sort of off the wall and
ridiculous is now number one in late
night so anyway i do apologize for
having to
take in that minute of your life away
and again if you thought it was
interesting or funny or informative in
any way you cannot watch this show
anymore i can't i can't have people like
you watching this show